the desert is still the night seems
endless
silent and at peace until it's pierced
by the sound of gunshots and screams
deep in the sahara the scp foundation is
waging war against a newly discovered
enemy
a squad of foundation agents is
retreating trying to get away from the
ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means
but their rifles were no match for the
reality-bending entities of the kingdom
of abaddon the retreating agents cover
one another as they make their way back
to the extraction point
the enemy force advances agents that are
caught too close to the sorcerers of
abaddon disintegrated to thin air this
is not an enemy they can defeat
the scp agents need to get back to base
and relay what they have found to their
superiors
out of the hundreds of agents sent into
the sahara that night
only a handful make it out alive they
are debriefed by their superiors at the
foundation who classified the anomalous
humanoids under the highest of threat
levels
the kingdom of abaddon is a threat the
kingdom of abaddon
must be eliminated reconnaissance done
prior to the disastrous mission had
alerted the foundation to the presence
of anomalies in the region
but they had no idea how strong the
anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abaddon humanoids
were responsible for the deaths of no
fewer than 75 foundation personnel
and had stolen at least 12 different
items from the foundation
the leaders of the scp foundation tasked
research team omega-5 with developing a
weapon that would be capable of
destroying the kingdom of abaddon once
and for all
the weapon they are researching must be
capable of long-range destruction
because the moment any foundation agent
gets close to the area
they are vaporized by the reality
manipulating powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twins of
god and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
o51 051 is popular in the scp foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality
making him the perfect person to lead
such a project
and o51 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for
to defeat the kingdom of abaddon item001
and so the omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item001 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy
the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness
and eventually death to stop the
radiation problems the omega-5 research
group
intensifies the containment procedures
o51 receives reports from the higher-ups
that the kingdom of abaddon has attacked
another foundation facility in sudan
long-range defense is needed asap the
administrator puts more pressure on
omega 5
and especially its leader 051 to solve
the problems of item 01
and develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end
working tirelessly to create a safe and
controllable item001
entity although there are signs that the
weapon will work
it is still unpredictable when item001
is initiated
the host entity becomes paralyzed
suffers severe cerebral hemorrhaging
and soon a new host is needed before
testing can begin again
and that's not the only thing that goes
wrong whenever the anomaly is put into a
new host
sudden and random destruction of on-site
structures and personnel take place
o51 knows though that if this power can
be harnessed and controlled in the right
way
that it could be the weapon that the
foundation needs to wipe out the kingdom
of abaddon once and for all
in order to control item001 o51 has a
mine kill switch implanted in its host's
brains
o51 can activate the implant to
incapacitate its host and immediately
stop the unwanted destruction
countless hosts are terminated by this
mind kill switch in the early trials
conducted by the omega 5 team
but progress continues to be made and
eventually a hypothesis is formulated
perhaps the disastrous side effects of
item 001 can be offset by spreading the
anomaly across
multiple subjects they theorize that the
immense mental load of the anomaly can
be distributed among
several hosts thus reducing the toil it
takes on each
and giving them the ability to control
its immense power
but o51 and the omega-5 team need more
data
and for that they need more bodies they
consult with the director of site 17
and it is concluded that the nearby town
of san marco would be an appropriate
place to get the additional test
subjects they require
on a quiet sunday morning omega-5 along
with support from a squad of armed scp
agents storm into the san marcos de la
vida sterna church during the middle of
mass
they gather up a number of the younger
congregants and bring them back to the
site where item 001 is housed
the researchers quickly ran through
their new supply of test subjects though
and omega 5 would need to get even more
if their research was to continue
instead of going back and forth between
the testing facility and san marcos
051 decided to move the entire item 001
operation to the town itself
he renames the town testing site 001
and omega 5 rounds up 23 of the
healthiest subjects they can find for
use in the next series of research tests
a few weeks after occupying the town of
san marco omega-5 makes its most
substantial progress yet just as they
theorized
by spreading out the anomaly of item 01
across a specific group of hosts
they can control its powers the test may
have cost the lives of almost everyone
in the town
but the ends certainly justify the means
the kingdom of abaddon poses an
existential threat to the scp foundation
after all
and thanks to this research they will
soon have a weapon capable of bringing
them victory
the foundation administer criticized
o51's methods
but can't argue with his results
unfortunately
o51 has a dark secret a secret that
disturbs even the most hardened and
loyal members of omega-5
a secret that has to do with the item001
hosts the host that omega-5 has made its
major progress with
are not the ordinary test subjects
normally used by the foundation
no the test subjects o51 makes his
breakthrough with
our children nine of them to be exact
all between four and eleven years old
despite being told specifically by the
foundation administrator to only test on
adults
the research required o51 to break the
chain of command
and follow the science down the path of
lead the children are contained in a
reinforced bunker where only 051
and a select few have access they are
technically alive
but are functionally brain dead the
group of nine children share a hive mind
that can process
information and more importantly can
unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly
creating and controlling a devastating
power
but not everyone is thrilled with what
they've achieved members of omega 5 are
haunted by the screams of the children
that they forced to be part of their
weapons development program
they describe their merging with item
001 as being a process that rips out
their souls
and replaces them with something much
more sinister
in fact all of omega five regret what
they have been a part of
and what they've done all except oh
five one the nine children can channel
unprecedented amounts of energy from an
unknown origin that omega-5 hypothesizes
comes from an extra-dimensional source
which is then used to unbind atoms at
the quantum level
when the right activation words are
spoken it appears as though this
tremendous power gives the children the
ability to annihilate anything
in the entire universe it's a gun to
end all guns and only o51
has the key to control it the nine
children work so well with an item001
that omega-5 reclassifies it to include
the nine children themselves
they are not just the entity housing or
controlling item001
they permanently become item001
once omega-5 has a better understanding
of item 001
they begin to run tests to find out the
full extent of its abilities
first they test the distance item 001
can reach the initial test that omega-5
carries out is on a steel rod placed
five kilometers away
o51 orders the children to destroy the
target
moments later the phone next to o51
begins to ring
when he picks it up the observer tasked
with watching the pole is on the other
end
he informs 051 that the steel rod has
been completely vaporized
051 is not satisfied though he has
another pole sent
out this time placed 8 000 kilometers
away from the nine children
o51 asks the children to destroy that
rod
almost immediately the phone rings again
the target
has been vaporized 051 smiles
the next series of tests omega 5 runs on
item001 are to determine the maximum
size of an object that can be destroyed
the tests start out with a steel sphere
three meters in diameter
placed one thousand kilometers from item
001
051 orders the children to destroy the
object
it is instantly vaporized o51 has seen
enough small tests
it's time for something big so he does
something that will later be questioned
by everyone at the scp foundation
he orders the nine children to destroy a
church of the broken god worship site in
turkey
not long after the destruction order is
given to item 001
reports begin coming in the worship site
has been obliterated with no observable
damage to the surrounding area
deadly and precise o51 closes his eyes
and takes a deep breath
he looks as if he's overcome by an
immense spiritual experience
he opens his eyes leans over to the
children and whispers the name of
something
later that day o51 finds out that the
target he had named has been vaporized
the success of omega 5 in item001 is
relayed to the administration of the
foundation
they are so impressed that they make
plans to use item001 to eliminate the
abaddon threat once
and for all however one of the heads of
the foundation
administrator williams has major
concerns about the way 0-5-1 is running
the program
the updates that 0-5-1 has been sending
have become less scientific
and more philosophical more
spiritual administrator williams sends a
letter to o51 reassuring him that he is
doing good work
but once the mission to destroy the
kingdom of avadon is completed
o51 will be promoted to director and
reassigned to the newly constructed
site-19
for the good of the foundation and maybe
the rest of the world
he'll be permanently moved away from
item001
051's response is short and to the point
i am fine administrator the project is
finished
we will complete our task when you
arrive
administrator williams arrives at
site-001 a few days later
he is greeted by 0-5-1 and the omega-5
team
williams can't help but notice that
0-5-1 has a strange look in his eyes
it is the look of a crazed man who has
been lost in his work
and who has perhaps lost himself
williams puts the thought away though
and walks with o51
and his accompanying agents to the
viewing area where the powers of item
zero zero one will be demonstrated
administrator williams and the other
agents want from a protected viewing
room as o51 enters the chamber of his
new super weapon
it's time to see if their weapon that
has had so much time effort sweat
tears and especially blood poured into
it
will have been worth it everyone watches
as o51 leans over and says the name of
the abaddon citadel to the nine children
all at once they start to glow no one
observing can see what has happened in
the far-off kingdom
but they know something big has happened
the administrator is thrilled
but notices something 0-5-1 hesitated
the moment while leaning over the
children before standing
back up did he whisper something else to
them
and then administrator williams
vaporizes pulled apart at an atomic
level before he has the chance to scream
what's going on the agent standing next
to where administrator williams
previously existed began to yell and
pull out their guns
they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 0-5-1
and the 9 children are located the armed
agents rush into the room
but 0-5-1 is gone nine children
are still over the next few weeks o51 is
reported to be seen
several times by scp agents however no
one is able to catch him
and it appears as though other members
of the scp foundation have also gone
awol as well perhaps joining him on the
run
it is unclear what his plan is but the
reports from the reconnaissance team
sent into the sahara make it obvious
what the result of his first command to
the children was
there isn't a single humanoid or
building left in the kingdom
of abaddon but even with this victory
the highest levels of the scp foundation
have an ominous thought lurking in the
back of their minds
where did o51 go and what is he planning
to do
next following the improper use of item
001 leading to the untimely death of a
high-ranking foundation staff member
the weapon was deemed too dangerous and
containment procedures were implemented
due to the high amount of radiation they
were found to emit the nine children
were placed into lead-lined bags
and buried under 50 meters of concrete
beneath the church of san marcos de la
vida eterna
though all the children continued to be
functionally brain-dead
they still display signs of life despite
their containment
and by order of the overseer council
have been classified as a thaumial
entity
now go watch scp-5000 the suit or
scp-1730
what happened at site 13 for more epic
tales from the scp archives